in this video we will cover the power
rule which really simplifies our life
when it comes to taking derivatives
especially derivatives of polynomials
you are probably already familiar with
the definition of a derivative the limit
as delta x approaches 0 of f of x plus
delta x
minus f of x all of that over delta x
and it really just comes out of trying
to find the slope of a tangent line at
any given point but we're going to see
what the power rule is it simplifies our
life we won't have to take these
sometimes complicated limits and we're
not going to prove it in this video but
we'll hopefully get a sense of of how to
use it and in future videos we'll get a
sense of why it makes sense and even
prove it so the power rule just tells us
that if i have some function f of x and
it's equal to some power of x
so x
to the
n power where n does not
equal 0. so n can be anything it can be
positive and negative it could be it
doesn't it does not have to be an
integer the power rule tells us that the
derivative of this
the derivative of this
f prime of x is just going to be equal
to
n so you're literally bringing this out
front
n
times x
n times x and then you just decrement
the power times x to the n
minus 1 power so let's do a couple of
examples just to make sure that that
actually makes sense
so let's ask ourselves well let's say
that f of x
was equal to x squared based on the
power rule what is f prime of x
going to be equal to
well in this situation our n is 2 so we
bring the 2 out front 2 times x to the
2 minus 1 power so that's going to be 2
times x to the first power which is just
equal to 2x that was pretty
straightforward
let's think about the situation where
let's say we have g of x
is equal to
x to the third power
what is g prime of x going to be in this
scenario well n is 3 so we just
literally pattern match here this is
you're probably finding the shockingly
straightforward so this is going to be
3
times x to the 3 minus 1 power or this
is going to be equal to 3
x squared and we're done in the next
video we'll think about whether this
actually makes sense let's do one more
example just to show it doesn't have to
necessarily apply to only these kind of
positive integers we could have a
scenario where maybe we have h of x
h of x is equal to x
to the
negative
100 power the power rule tells us that h
prime of x would be equal to what
well n is negative 100 so it's negative
100 x to the negative 100 minus 1 which
is equal to negative 100 x to the
negative 101. let's do one more
let's say we had z of x
z of x is equal to x
to the
2.571 power
and we are we are concerned with what is
z prime of x
well once again power rule simplifies
our life n is 2.571 so it's going to be
2.571
times x to the
2.571 minus 1 power so it's going to be
equal to
let me make sure i'm not falling off the
bottom of the page
2.571
times x to the 1.571
power hopefully you enjoyed that in the
next few videos we will not only expose
you to more properties of derivatives
we'll get a sense for why the power rule
at least makes intuitive sense and then
also
prove the power rule for a few cases